foreign
[Music]
we begin in Turkey where results are
coming in from the most closely
contested presidential and parliamentary
elections in decades the main opposition
candidate disputes results coming from
the state-run news agency and says that
he's ahead but the governing party says
that President Richard is leading let's
get straight to Istanbul for the latest
here's my colleague Sami zedan Sami
Adrian it's a nail-biting night with
people waiting watching to see these
results results which will determine the
future of this country and also its
influence regionally and globally let's
not forget there's something of a
difference between the two main
candidates when it comes to some of
their foreign policy orientation towards
Russia towards the west and so on well
the big question tonight of course is
results let's bring you up to speed with
some of the results coming in we're
going with the results being provided by
anadolo news agency I'll clarify why
that's important later those are the
news agency that's the official state
news agency results and just moments ago
this is how they stood
with president erdogan in the lead with
51 of votes his main Challenger command
coach darolu with 42 of votes and the
third Challenger for the presidency
sinan Owen with just over five percent
of votes and interestingly or unusually
fourth candidate who actually pulled out
of the race Muharram India you might
remember that well he's got half a
percent of votes even though he's out
probably can be explained by early votes
cast well this is so far with about 61
of votes counted or that that number is
changing in fact as as I'm looking now
at the live feed coming into me here 63
percent of votes have been counted but
the numbers still fairly close with
President erdogan still in the lead
there we've got correspondence covering
this story right across turkia Hashem is
following events for us from the
headquarters of the opposition party
also in Ankara following developments
from the headquarters of Arc party and
we've got Cinema
watching the streets in turkia's
economic and cultural heart of Istanbul
and of course zainer outside of the
major cities in the Heartland keeping
her finger on the pulse of the people
deep in the Turkish interior
we'll get to those correspondence later
but first we're going to start right now
with Hashem live for us in anchor and
Hashem we've already already heard some
noises from the opposition concerning
those results are we seeing a dispute
emerging
they are they are disputing the
preliminary results which are coming
from the state run anatolo news agency
and they say that they were not
representative of the reality of the
balance and they say that it's going to
be just a matter of time and that by the
time we get to 80 percent of the oval
overall votes we're likely to see their
candidate taking a lead their crowds are
starting to gather outside the
headquarters of the CHP party they they
have we can hear them chanting Pro
parties slogans and this the this sense
of anxiety and tension which has been
mounting is something we're predicted
everybody predicted over the last few
days because
we knew this is going to be a tight race
and this is why all the parties have
been saying we have to monitor the vote
count and we have to ensure that there
are no irregularities during the count
now the CHP dispatched one of these top
leaders
of Istanbul and this is what he had to
say a while ago
unfortunately as in every election the
anadolu agency proved itself incompetent
and incapable once again but this will
change during our leadership we can no
longer talk about a credible and
reputable on a dollar agency when we
look at these results we can say that
our esteemed leader
kamalu will become the next president
so now the opposition now is looking at
the latest developments the latest
account and I think this is why they are
trying and they're hoping to achieve
they're hoping to be able to get to the
point where their main candidate gets to
something like 47 48 percent of the
hoping at the same time to see the other
candidate from uh sinan again
get to something like six percent this
is going to be good news for them
because it could be a strong indication
that they are going to go to a a runoff
and if they go to the runoff they say
the Dynamics could definitely change
then and then you have to talk about
different scenarios different politics
which are going to be at play Sammy
foreign
reporting to us there and of course we
should remember that there is a
parliamentary election going on let me
bring you up to speed with that we have
about 53 percent uh according to the
numbers which have been revealed once
again by anadolo news agency that's the
official news agency
53 for the ruling Alliance and about 32
for the opposition Alliance and at this
point while they've counted about 45
of the votes for the Parliamentary
election let's go now to rasul Sardar
he's standing by live for us at the arc
party headquarters in Ankara and we
heard there from Hashem rasul about how
the opposition is looking at these
results they're not very happy with it
how how are art party officials reacting
to that
well Sami so far we haven't seen any
official statement being released by our
party's officials however here you can
see the supporters of President erdogan
and our party right behind me waving
their flags and there is a loud music
they are dancing and they're waiting for
their leaders uh president rajapai aired
one to arrive to the headquarter of AG
party in Ankara and to deliver a speech
in the very balcony of the main building
of the headquarters so usually president
erdogan after casting his ward he would
wait in Istanbul and then late in the
night he will come to Ankara to deliver
the speech however this time the
opposite has happened right after cats
is water in Istanbul he flew to Ankara
he's expected to deliver recipes to here
here to Turkey and also his supporters
and then flew back to Istanbul so the
hopes here are running higher and higher
you can see that the vibe the the the
the the the excitement of his supporters
is is is improving here because the
results are giving them I hope them I
hope that they might be able to win the
election in this very first uh first
round so Sami it has been a very
contested election so both leaders
through their uh election campaign have
promised a lot president erdogan was
simply focusing on the advancement of
the that the company has gone through
the progress that the country has made
and he was promising even a more
powerful turkey inside and also an a
more assertive turkey International in
the international Arena as well
many consider this election to be
turkey's most significant in recent
history
erdogan voted in Istanbul where he began
his political career
he has reshaped turkey over the last two
decades his supporters believe he has
made the country more powerful and
prosperous
we want everyone to vote because the
independence and future of the country
is at stake we came here to vote for the
stability and the growth of our country
to continue
stability and continuity have been
keywords throughout erdogan's election
campaign
he is now prompting a more assertive
turkey in the international Arena
he ended his campaign by visiting Aya
Sofia Istanbul's famous mosque and
historic cultural site to appeal his
conservative base
[Applause]
after more than two decades in power he
now faces his most difficult challenge
six opposition parties have joined
forces for this presidential and
parliamentary elections with opposition
leader Kamal kharistarolo chosen as
their Unity candidate
the supporters are growing more
confident that he will be turkey as next
president
power has declined at
the time the rule of law has vanished
justice has vanished I want my country
to become better in terms of Justice the
rule of law and living conditions
election campaign his main messages were
change and whole he promises a more
inclusive democracy at home and stronger
ties with the West
concluded his campaign by visiting anat
Kabir the Muslim or the founder of the
Turkish Republic Mustafa Kemal a tattoo
that is regarded as a symbol of
secularism and republicanism in the
country
along with the symbolic Maneuvers many
in Turkey believe the economy will be
the most important factor determining
the election outcome people are facing
rocketing prices as the country has one
of the highest inflation rates in the
world that has been exacerbated by the
two earthquakes in February to win
outright a candidate must get more than
half of the world If no candidate get at
least 50 plus one would in the first
round the presidential election will be
decided in a second round on May 28th
between the two candidates who received
the most Awards Ankara
and as rasul was explaining there the
cost of living crisis well it's been one
of the major issues if not the major
issue for many Turks in this election
guiding the voting behavior we're told
let's bring you up to speed with some of
the numbers to bring it into perspective
well we're told that inflation peaked
last year in October reaching
85.5 of course the annual rate of
inflation for last year 64 that were the
highest October was the highest in 24
years well now it's about half of that
around 43 percent the last figures
monthly figures for April the Turkish
lira well it lost nearly 80 percent of
its value to the US dollar in five years
largely because of the interest rate
Council though of course there were
other factors and the government says
reducing interest rates though has
increased exports and increased
investment
and they would point to the growth
figure the economy growing 5.6 last year
compared to 2021
unemployment is down the jobless rate
dipped to 10 percent in 2022 from around
14 in 2020 but obviously still quite
High a pain for many people
well uh when it comes to economics and
commerce of course it's one city
Istanbul that is the Beating Heart of
this country's economy there's been a
big push of focus on Istanbul by the
major political parties
is in one of the major commercial
districts taksim Square in Istanbul we
can go to her live there now and I
understand synonym
it's been an unusually quiet day for
taksim on a Sunday right indicative that
bats people are more interested in
elections than shopping right now
well it seems like that Sami today there
was a heavy turnout in every Pull
Station at least in Istanbul but however
this is Sunday the weather was sunny
during the daytime it was very nice like
springtime but uh Street just right
behind me uh we see only tourists mostly
from the Middle East we don't see locals
it's unusually quiet of course the
earthquake actually had an impact on the
uh business of taxim square many people
were afraid but of course it has been
nearly three months and the area was
Reviving again but today uh many people
say that it's unusually quiet uh during
the during last week during the last
days before the election the opposition
was also giving some warnings that there
might be some tension especially about
the security of the ballot uh ballot
boxes they should be protected probably
many were afraid that since everything
was neck and neck before the election
and neither if the government loses they
wouldn't accept it or if the opposition
loses they wouldn't accept it probably
this is why many people are watching the
situation following the situation from
their homes but surprisingly taxem is
very quiet which is an unusual Sami
all right thanks so much synonym console
all over there reporting to us live from
Istanbul Let's uh remember of course
there are many people voting around this
country not just in the major cities of
Ankara and Istanbul and many of them in
rural heartlands
some of those people have been impacted
by those earthquakes which hit just
three months ago and these elections
coming you know after people are still
struggling with the out Fallout from
that more than 50 000 people died when
those two earthquakes hit on February
the 6th the World Health Organization
describing it as the worst natural
disaster in Europe in a century and 14
million people across 11 provinces were
affected many criticized the initial
responses being simply too slow the
government's also been accused of
failing to enforce building safety
regulations leading to more damage the
UN says at least 1.5 million people were
left homeless
and the Turkish government estimates
rebuilding could cost more than 103
billion dollars
has been out and about in some of those
areas she joins us now live from gazi
and tap where hundreds of thousands of
survivors have been out to vote first of
all Zenith tell us about how easy it was
for them to get out and cast their
ballot
well it was a logistical challenge we
did watch a stream a steady stream of
Voters arrive at makeshift polling
stations because thousands and thousands
of buildings either collapsed or are
damaged schools hospitals so the
authorities set up container cabins as
polling stations we also went to the bus
terminal the main bus terminal in hatai
Province and we saw people arrive from
across the country people were it
excited is the wrong word they were
determined they were determined to make
their voices heard because a lot of them
were angry especially people in hatai
because people there feel that the
authorities let them down they did not
receive help in the first few days in
the aftermath of those earthquakes and
they say that they still have been left
alone to fend for themselves little
reconstruction work has begun but we saw
people determined arriving at polling
stations many of them actually live in
tents in in containers they still don't
have have homes and that is why the
election was so important for them they
are hoping that the man that they vote
for will start the Reconstruction
process will build them build them you
know homes now but at the end of the day
the political landscape did not change
yes the earthquakes the economy they
loomed over the election campaign but in
Turkey loyalties rarely shake and as
you've seen with the results that are
coming in the ACT party the president
maintained his support in his
traditional strongholds in a number of
the Quake hit provinces
all right thanks so much today capturing
the spirit and the vibe there from
turkey's Southern and Eastern provinces
well of course this is an election that
has gripped people on all sides it's
it's really hard to try and remember
another election in turkey's modern
political history where people have been
so captivated and so polarized let's
talk a little bit about that right now
with our political analyst who joins us
here Ali chakriola good to have you back
with us Ali so first of all maybe it's
good to try and recap the results is
where we are once again we're looking at
the results coming in from anadola news
agency that's the state news agency and
they're saying now
69 of the votes have been counted 69
that's a significant proportion of votes
51 of those votes have been captured so
far by President
erdogan and 40 three percent so a little
increase there for his main Challenger
from jhop
he now is put at having captured 43
I think now it's time to talk about the
points it's
51.14 according to aladolo
first of all
is this is important right because
if we get below 50 percent this is going
to a second round right so this is why
it's very important to pay attention to
the small percentages am I right yes and
it's been reported by journalists that
the reason why
the main opposition party is objecting
is because many of the polling stations
where Kalisto is ahead
has been objected by
The Arc party people and that's why
their results are not Health officials
yes are held up and so I'm suggesting
that this could change once that is
sorted out that's the implication if
this is a correct diagnosis by right the
journals if that is so the difference
could uh very quickly change how long
does it take to sort out an argument at
the polling station like this are we
talking hours we talk working days or
weeks we could talk about hours in some
instances or days
so it might not be over
anytime soon right but the other issue I
think is clear that the opposition
candidate is not approaching 50 percent
so as much as some people were
predicting yes and just a couple of
hours ago many people expected that the
first round would be won by the
opposition right and we will I'd say we
were trying to be very careful with
running away with polls because polls
have a history in this country of not
being the most reliable shall we put it
but also experts have I been talking to
experts and almost everyone was
expecting that you know it will be
cliched early in the first round with
slim margin but he's not getting close
what's emerging out of this picture is
that
a right-wing conservative such as
akbartier together with sinan who is a
splinter from the a nationalist party
hence a new Coalition could emerge if
erdogan cannot be elected in the in this
round in the second round when we get to
the second round some of those voters
for the third presidential candidates in
and Owen are more likely to go over to
rajat because they're both within the
right-wing camp and most likely Iran
also would engage in a negotiation to
actually ask his supporters to support
erdogan in return for something some for
an endorsement we don't know what but
all right we've got to also talk about
the Parliamentary election that's going
on we can't forget that's going on and
the the results coming in so far once
again I want to point out because we
know there's the opposition of disputing
sure some of the results this is by
anadola news agency that's the official
state news agency and they're saying
that according to the latest counting of
votes 52 so more than half the votes of
parliament have been counted and the
picture well it's a similar one a lead
for the ruling Alliance they have 53
percent of the votes and the opposition
Alliance at 32 when you look at both of
these numbers
it does look like there is that that
earthquake those concerns about the
earthquake the economic problems haven't
taken as big of a bite out of the
support for the conservative group right
well the predictions of seeds is very
difficult uh things in Parliament see
it's in Parliament because it all
depends on the distribution of words
across provinces and we have seen some
results but the whole picture is not
clear is saying about 335 for the room
that's more than yeah for the ruling
Alliance but it's we we should take it
with a pinch of salt it's a picture of
salt because you need a model to
actually predict the seed Distribution
on the basis of on the partial results
right however what's emerging here is
that that's because of the proportional
representation yeah
very complicated
and it looks like the strategy that was
followed by the incumbent
People's Alliance actually worked to
their favors and nobody expected that
because they adopted to have their own
lists separate from one another they
didn't have a single list which actually
gives them an advantage in the Don
system they adopted
separate lists but despite that
disadvantage they still are managing to
capture the majority in the parliament
which actually is very comfortable for
the new president if that president
right happens to be erdogan he will have
the comforting support from the
Parliamentary majority of the
Parliamentary otherwise it says split uh
system between President and Parliament
president let's see we've still got some
hours to go Ali we'll be back to talk
about this well thank you so much for
joining us and explaining that to us let
me quickly wrap the results where we are
now 70 percent of votes have been
counted according to anadola news agency
president erdogan still in the lead
according to the state news agency with
51. he gets interesting
.06 with kamalu the leader of the
opposition according to the official
news agency he's at now 43.12
there's plenty more to keep an eye on
obviously here but for now I'm going to
hand you back to Adrian in daha
thank you